hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number 70
q and a segment we are raring to go
we are in the break along with collating
questions
uh our awesome moderator tells us that
in our breaker yes told us that um
tell us that uh the susian rhyming
scheme
is known as anapastic tetrameter and a
past deck referring to
the emphasis on
tetrameter referring to uh the number of
syllables
uh that one tends to uh
combine into into a set so if we go like
one two three four one two three four
one two three four
one two three four one two three four
one two three four
so you tend to have two sets of those so
it is less meaningful when you use just
numbers
yeah yeah it's it's less compelling um
it is like iambic pentameter except with
different parameters though
sorry i'm not going to pull that off am
i no that was that was a strange move
that you tried to pull back there and i
was i was just not having anything yeah
all right yeah
i take it back i regret it i uh i feel
ashamed
chagrined i am oh we lost one of our
cats
i'm sure i'm sure she'll turn up
okay shall we proceed yes we've got
three questions from
episode 67 uh no
69 i don't know why it says 67 there
and uh and then a question from discord
and then we'll start in with your
questions from today
first one um
i'm surprised i included this one here
because i don't actually i don't
remember this uh what are your thoughts
on the uk recently reporting almost zero
influenza cases
don't you find it odd so i don't know
this um but i know that uh influenza
cases are down in the us are supposedly
down so
i don't want to i don't want to accept a
an assumption an axiom of the question
but um
but we know that in the u.s uh flu cases
are supposedly
are reported to be down uh what you know
don't you find it odd
is the question well i don't find it odd
i do not find it odd i don't find it on
at all in fact my explanation to
my doctor when i saw her for an annual
exam
last october as to why i was not going
to get the flu shot
this year was i have so
little potential exposure to the flu
that i don't think i need it
yep um i see this here given behaviors
given lockdowns
right yeah and you know for what it's
worth we predicted that this would
happen that all kinds of
infectious diseases would have a much
harder time transmitting that we might
succeed against them quite dramatically
during
during this year i also think it is
possible
that great britain
has a benefit that comes from its being
an
island obviously it's not really
perfectly an island given the tunnel
and and all but the point is
lanes what well there's always been a
condo but my point about planes would be
that the airline industry in order to
continue
to function has gotten very very serious
about how to control
covet and therefore the procedures the
rigorous procedures
that accompany mean that well a there's
a lot fewer people flying into britain
b they're coming in through a conduit in
which there is
a great deal of care being taken so
obviously
it can get in and it could spread like
wildfire inside of britain
yeah but the degree of control i don't
know how porous the border at the
channel has remained i don't know what
kinds of blocks there have been
yeah i don't know either um but i guess
i would say
a combination of a britain had a
very bad phase with covid because of the
um novel versions of the virus that were
circulating
that resulted in well i mean sorry but
also because of their uh incompetent
response early on i think
yes but we have a we have this problem
where
every time you have an uptick it causes
an increase
in measures to prevent it and
so the point is okay incompetence leads
to
uh rapid spread leads to panic leads to
lockdowns and other measures
and so the point is it is very likely
that flu season
overlapped a set of more stringent
measures
that resulted in less circulation of
regular flu yes um
and that that wouldn't be terribly
surprising and it's one of these things
that could have gone differently if
timing was slightly different or
you know maybe they got lucky with
respect to what made it across the
border that it could have come across
the border in large numbers but didn't
manage to
but anyway there are lots of ways that
you could imagine a population would be
isolated enough and behave in a way that
would prevent spread enough to see
very low caseload absolutely
okay next question from last episode or
last week um
that's the same question okay oh this
person asked asked twice and didn't get
through the first time okay
are there different rates of dna
mutations in different species and if so
what are the consequences of a higher or
lower rate of mutation
um no doubt there are
um basically we have evidence of this i
i did not go and look
for the research on it but we certainly
know it at some level of resolution
um as for whether this is
finely parsed between relatively closely
related species i don't know what is
certainly true
and in fact even how you measure it
because the point is it varies across
the genome
so you know you would have to do you
know what
are you averaging and then you would
have to figure out yeah what to wait
there's even differences in like rate
assumptions of background rates of
mutation
uh when you're trying to when people are
trying to calibrate molecular clocks and
such
um based on some empirical work i
believe yep
and it's just been a long time since
i've looked at that directly but yep
but the the basic answer to the question
is that you'll have
a cost from mutations that do not
contribute
but at a lineage level you will have
some advantage that comes from a greater
ability to track
change right to discover new
opportunities and to track change and so
you know a population in which you froze
mutation at zero
would have the advantage of not having
harmful mutations show up
and cause damage but it would have the
um the cost of being stuck
evolutionarily and so you can imagine
somewhere between those you can play a
game about how much mutation do you want
something to predict that the more
variable the environment the more
rapidly changing the environment
um the higher rate of mutation will
evolve in response sort of like you know
you know lockdowns happen after the
uptick already happens but you know
the selective response happens after the
thing has already
um revealed itself in this case the rate
of environmental change
right you might predict that probably we
will see it but i would point out that
this
uh goes to this question of explorer
modes and
at least in my opinion a lot of the
ability
to track change is going to be housed in
a
layer that is not dictated by mutation
in other words there are evolutionary
mechanisms that i believe are yet to be
explored that allow
a much safer mechanism for dealing with
change so do i hear you advocating for
the use of explorer modes to discover
explorer modes uh that will be true it
will be fractal
i will point out though that um mutation
in the case of something like
hiv turns out to be
part of its gift for escaping
uh control of the immune system so a
high mutation rate in a rna virus that
doesn't because the dna because the
genes are not paired
there's a high mutation rate and that
high mutation rate is an adaptation in
that case
very good okay final question from
episode 69
uh invokes someone with whom i'm not
familiar but the concept will be
familiar to both of us
um vesatsuki you know vesatsuki
vesatsuki's epigenetic compensation
shows successive rat generations cope
with a stressful legacy via dynamic
phenotypic modifications
humans too the question is so
i don't know vasatsuki it may well be
that i have some vasatsuki papers on my
computer here but um
you know i think the kind of work that
is being alluded to here with regard to
um to epigenetic change um
in rats um let's see there's a paper
about i don't remember it was rats or
mice but
you know one of the one of the models
one of the model organisms that are used
in labs
um dads males
being exposed to um
fear-inducing stuff before
they become fathers yeah and then in the
species the offspring never meet their
dads they don't know them at all the
only thing that dad contributes to sperm
and so there's like fear on board the
adult
male rat before he becomes a dad because
it's a capped a situation
the experimenters can guarantee that the
dad never comes in contact with his
offspring
and those offspring i believe it was and
maybe even the f2 maybe even the
generation after that
actually show a more fearful um
phenotype than the average rats do which
has been taken as evidence for
epigenetic passing on fearfulness for
you know
sort of lamarckian um acquisition of
personality traits that happen in the in
the adult lifetime of a
parent who never meets the offspring yep
um
we don't we don't have any such
experimental evidence from humans as far
as i know
okay we do um yeah there's a bunch of
stuff here
at the narrow genetic level um there is
work for intergenerational
transfer of uh anti-famine responses for
example oh yes
yes there is so anyway these things
definitely exist they exist at the
molecular level just as they apparently
do
so that's going to be physiological
right not behavioral like
multi-generational response to famine
it's going to be
about basically holding on more tightly
to resources being more ten
more susceptible to to to building up
building up fat and retaining fat yeah
right i believe so right um
you know you have to be really careful
because sometimes there are lots of
ways that experimentally you could make
that inference and it wouldn't be
justified based on what you actually
measured yeah i haven't spent any time
with the literature
yeah um but nonetheless there we do have
good evidence of that there are several
different things that work this way but
i would also point out
with respect to humans there's a whole
different pathway for this to work and
it comes through the
cultural layer in which um you know
if your parent i mean look actually this
sucks very well yes of course and i
think that's more interesting
too just to be clear like this question
is clearly about
the molecular so what we've called in
our book so the epigenetic sensor
stricto
the the modern molecular sense of
epigenetic meaning above the genome but
still at the molecular level um
modifiers of genes and you're talking
about what we've called epigenetic
sensulato
the the broad meaning of effects
um everything going downstream but
doesn't
isn't inherently molecular might be
cultural might be developmental it might
be environmental
yep so uh the basic answer to your
question is it exists at a molecular
level but there's a much richer
landscape of ways that this can happen
for a human being right and i was just
going to point out
that for example the
um concern about anti-semitism and
genocide
clearly is transmitted from one
generation to the next
and you know among jews sure
um that they're uh you know after the
holocaust
that these things there were deliberate
mechanisms for transmitting them
and it results in mindset that uh
presumably has no genetic component you
know that is to say the difference
between what took place before the
holocaust and what took place after the
holocaust has no molecular component
yeah
so i'm i'm curious i'm interested to
know
um to what degree there are you know
molecular
epigenetic mechanisms of things like
mindset in humans i think obviously
because we are more software than any
other organism on the planet
as we have said here and elsewhere many
many times
um it is more likely that most of these
things uh hey zach you want to fix the
cameras
um
yep um we don't know what he's doing in
there no
no probably drugs
no matter are you doing drugs no you
could just put us both on thank you
probably that's reassuring
um let's see what was i saying so the
molecular um
certainly there is epigenetic censulato
uh stuff going on wherein humans are
passing on changes that have
effects downstream at the you know at
the genetic level in terms of you know
who ends up leaving traces in the next
generation um
i don't know that um we have
any uh evidence of things like
personality like the fear response that
that
is evidenced in this research that i was
talking about in either rats or mice
um so even like the um
multi-generational response to famine
uh that we that i think there is no
evidence for that is a strictly physical
and you know
all of these borders are a little bit
porous but a physiological response
whereas fear is yes is coming from the
physiology but seeing was like it's also
more about software
yeah as well right well it's behavioral
who knows
yeah yeah yep all right okay
um this from the discord server this
week and i will say before i read it i
don't think you've seen it yet um
that i would love to spend a while
researching this before i answer the
question um but i didn't so
we're just gonna riff a little bit yikes
given that topic what do you think it is
i'm giving given that preamble what i'm
just gonna hide it i'm gonna give you
three guesses what topic
um i think it's about is it about
um what nixon knew about the kennedy
assassination it is
whoa yeah all right that's wild no it's
about potatoes
the fruit of potato plants is toxic raw
potatoes are toxic
mashed potatoes french fries and potato
chips are fueling obesity and heart
disease
are potatoes telling us just not to eat
them should we leave potatoes alone
who will win in the epic battle of man
versus potato
so this this is near and dear to my
heart because i am a potato fan from
the time i was tiny and um
and you know i have i have wondered this
and so there are a lot of places to go
here and we just don't have time to
assume
maybe there will be an episode down the
road totally devoted to potatoes
um but it just we'll go a couple places
here but one place to go to start
is our potatoes telling us just not to
eat them of course they are
right of you know of course they are
potatoes are the storage organs
of the potato plants the things that we
call potatoes are the storage organs of
the potatoes potato plants
and almost nothing in this world is
designed to be eaten there are very very
few things
and um actually i'll let i'll try to do
a sort of a teaching
thing here and not say what those very
few things are until the end of our
conversation
here um so you know think those of you
listening about what those very few
things are that are produced
in which the organism that is producing
them has the intention of them being
consumed
by some other organism and then be very
well aware that things like potatoes are
not on that list so
of course they don't want us to eat them
and of course there are secondary
compounds in them
as in all of the um god what's the
family potatoes
uh the it's the nightshades it's uh i
forgot it um
okay well so i just drew both of us drew
a blank on the family of
uh potatoes that includes stolen ac yeah
thank you
um includes tomatoes includes eggplants
and um yes a lot of people actually
can't
abide any of those things and um
and it may well be that these particular
secondary compounds
are doing something that is distinct
from what other secondary compounds do
and are bad for many humans i would say
it's
really unlikely that for instance incans
who and and other high andean peoples
i think the potatoes were i think the
potatoes
were domesticated before the incans i'm
not positive about that okay
um so the the pre-incan andean peoples
who domesticated the potatoes and the
incans who came in and
took over everything and then the
colombians who came in and took over
everything after that
um that all of those early peoples
probably have an ability to deal with
potatoes better than the rest of us do
and it's possible for instance that
potato rich cultures
like the irish like to some degree
western europeans have a better ability
to deal with the particular compounds in
the solanaceae than than the rest of us
but i'm not sure about that
i am a little surprised by the beginning
of your answer what's what's that
potatoes potatoes don't want to be eaten
my feeling is potatoes do want to be
eaten and that the same logic that
says that um chickens and
cows and other creatures have a good
deal
um you're going all pre-trans fallacy on
me here kinda
yeah okay no i just do it so here's the
thing um
potatoes have a great deal with humans
wild potatoes don't want to get eaten
wild potatoes don't want to get eaten
and certainly the features of the
potato chemically that make it dangerous
um derive from
their secondary compounds of the potato
designed as poisons yes they do poison
us
it is interesting how easily they are
removed um by various methods
well but maybe i mean i think that's
that's part of the question here is like
are they in fact
does uh blanching and boiling and
cooking and all that like actually um
release denature whatever it is like i
don't even know the nature of what the
secondary compounds and potatoes
is what the molecular nature is or what
it is that you do to them to apparently
render them i think it is both
water-soluble and denaturing by heat
so you know is it that when people have
bad reactions to potatoes
that that process has been
insufficiently done
or have we insufficiently domestic
through culinary means
or have we insufficiently domesticated
the potatoes such that they are actually
hanging on to something that we
can't even get rid of by proper culinary
means well look i think
a lot of this stuff comes down to
something upstream of any of it
that basically something in our modern
food supply
is causing the immune system to see
things in our guts that it's not
supposed to see
and so many of us have these paradoxical
allergies to things that we ate a lot of
right it's not potatoes but it's
industrially produced potatoes that have
been
that have been grown with uh
insecticides pesticides fertilizers
doesn't even have to be potatoes it
could be
that gmo corn and the insecticide and
other pesticides that are used
on it and it's not to be insecticide but
the pesticides that are used on it
are causing a breach
in the gut that then causes the immune
system to see whatever is in it and
whether it's honey or peanuts or wheat
or potatoes or all of the above the
the allergy is developed because the
immune system is supposed to be
insulated from the contents of the gut
and in this case it isn't
so i don't think you spilled that out
sufficiently took me a minute to realize
where you were going and we've been here
together
uh which is that the idea is that
um something in our diet as a result of
the industrial food
production pathway is creating leaky gut
syndrome it's creating holes in the gut
that is a breach between
um just as we were supposed to have a
blood brain barrier we're supposed to
have a gut sort of
immune system barrier yeah and we have
to be careful there
because we're going to get flagged okay
there is some immunity that is supposed
to contact what is in the gut but
there's a lot of the immune system that
isn't supposed to see it and what i'm
saying is that a breach of that boundary
now go i don't i don't know what i was
doing oh
sorry okay um but yes that a breach in
that boundary causes the immune system
to see something which it regards as
foreign basically it is programmed to
see anything it doesn't recognize as
foreign and it is supposed to be
shielded from seeing the contents of the
gut but instead it sees the stuff in the
gut
response to it as if it is a foreign
invader and then it generates an
immunity that's lasting okay so again
the thing that you skipped which is
where i was trying to go before
is the idea is that whatever it is that
is causing the holes in the gut
if you ate it with anything else those
things also even if they were produced
you know organically
and in the style in which they evolved
if you ate them in the same meal they
may trigger the same immune response and
you may become allergic to them
similarly so but that is the key point
that i think that you keep alighting
okay i agree that this is true the
reason that i'm aligning it is it
isn't that important in light of the
fact but it was the main thing that you
were saying
about i don't think it's even right it
doesn't have to be i agree it's
necessary to understand it at that level
but the reason that it doesn't matter in
practice
is that basically we are encountering a
lot of these molecules unless you're
taking steps to avoid these molecules
the point is
you have some chronic issue and then
it's what it so what you are likely to
do
i don't like this hold on what you are
likely to develop is an immunity
to whatever is most common in your diet
that triggers your immune system
okay but i i don't like this argument
because basically what you're saying all
is lost
you can't control things you know
there's there's no way to do for
instance an elimination diet and
actually you know
actually get there and you know the
problem is that it has to happen
you have to you have to have a more pure
diet as children
right and not and not have such
complexity but the idea that it's so
noisy you cannot fix it
strikes me as a hopeless note that i'm
not interested that's not that's not
what i'm saying
i'm not saying you can't fix it if you
have these issues and most of us
probably have one or more of them
so i would highly recommend figuring out
what's triggering you
doing an actual elimination diet in
which you cannot cheat at all and you
have to do it for
weeks in order to see the effect but my
point my own experience
says things that i didn't even know were
symptoms of anything
turned out to go away when i got wheat
out of my diet yeah so
you know you may not know that you even
have a problem until you try it but then
the point is
you the way to deal with this that's
best is to protect your kids from it so
they don't develop these immunities to
their food right we've done a good job
of that
i think imperfect but well it doesn't
have to be perfect the point is
the if you reduce the level of exposure
sufficiently low
you don't develop these immunities
hopefully our kids have evaded them
yeah if you have not had that
because you for whatever reason didn't
know
then the point is you'll develop the
immunities you're probably stuck with
them for life
at that point what you need to do is not
create more of them
and then figure out what sense foods
you're sensitive to and really avoid
them effectively and that is readily
possible it's a
pain in the butt i gotta tell you i
don't like having to be
you know i was recently describing to
some friends
uh our recent trip to italy and in italy
the idea that you can't eat
wheat is it's a rare phenomenon and we
don't speak italian and so
it's hard to even travel in italy and
even ask the question
but recently you mean in the before
times in the before times very late in
the before
times yeah um so anyway it's not easy
but getting that stuff out of your
um out of your diet is
a huge benefit to health if you have the
allergies
okay so um two things you you said i
can't believe you started with potatoes
don't want to get eaten and then you
didn't get to the punch line okay you
didn't go full service so i believe
potatoes
do want to get eaten in the same way
that a chicken or a cow does that
the fact is there are many more chickens
and cows than there are
bison and jungle fowl on earth that
evolutionarily it's a good deal
and so as long as they're humanely
treated the point is
you know so right
human selection has created organisms
that have benefited
from being part of our cuisine right but
with regard to the individual
plant yep um potatoes are not part of an
individual
plant that is designed to be eaten
pre-domestication by humans and so now
and i think we just need to move on yeah
now i want to uh provide the answer to
the question about what does want to be
and put aside the sort of pre-trans
fallacy answer
that is you have things that do want to
be eaten and things that don't
and now we know what's true and then
actually
domesticated animals and plants um
have a different deal set up with
organisms that that was your
objection um but um
pre-domestication and also including
domestication you have basically three
categories of things
um that are
well maybe four actually um in some ways
which
we don't list in our book but i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna pose a fourth one to
you here okay
um and i think it's a slightly different
category but there's basically three
things three types of things
that are designed to eat and it's milk
it's it's it's mammalian milk
and it is fruit which is uh created by
plants
after seed set as a reward for their
would-be distributors
um to you know eat the fruit and
distribute the seeds either by spitting
them out or pooping them out somewhere
far enough from the parent plant that
they get dispersed
and then nectar which is earlier in you
know some plants lives
uh the the the sugar reward and
i will i was gonna add a fourth one but
why are you making a face
well if we're going to say nectar then
we got to deal with all sorts of stuff
like what are they bayesian bodies and
acacia trees if we're talking about
things that are designed to feed other
creatures
i believe the list is going to be longer
yeah but we we eat we drink some nectar
not a lot not yeah it's pretty hot yeah
a little hibiscus
tea kind of yeah they even hibiscus that
we eat the whole flower yeah
we take the whole flower no no no plant
once yeah entire flower you did that's
interesting so you know it's possible
we've got like three days left to make
modifications on our books so maybe we
can maybe we should modify that but
maybe not
um but honey
um and it's you know it's not designed
to be eaten by us
yeah and just like mammal's milk is not
you know designed
the intention is not beaten by adults um
and you know we have we have
humans have turned that into you know
several culinary traditions
um but honey is food for baby bees
yep but it's going to be this is just
going to get so messy
if if the point is designed to be eaten
by anybody
you know the yolk of an egg is designed
to be eaten by
an embryo i mean you know so just you
you can
you can go a long way yeah um so
anyway but yeah fruit um fruit and milk
yeah from the uh point of view of
of us yeah okay so we have two susian
rhymes that are
um because of the nature of super chat
all squashed here um but i will try to
do
justice to them the wilk have spoke i'm
sad to say
what spoke the woke upon this day they
spoke that wokeness can't abide can't
tolerate
can't take in stride the slightest
thought or quip or fact that leaves
their workness unintact
hell yeah that's great yeah hashtag
clubhouse brilliant
um that was great yeah and then
i too tend to write aping seuss's milieu
but i must credit brother
shel silverstein too his rigorous rhymes
and fantastical bent delivered much
cleverly moral content
hashtag rock on dr weinstein awesome
yeah those are great oh man i hope this
please becomes a thing
yeah so please um if you if either of
you guys are on twitter
like put the if and if they're under the
word count character count
put those on twitter with the with the
hashtag
hashtag
what is it loose uh loose the soup loose
the seuss
um i should say that in tweeting out the
uh the link to the live stream
i wrote a little a little more sushi and
verse
but the character limit was onerous and
i ended up using emojis
to substitute for certain words to get
the
character count down and because it
rhymes actually you can infer even
though like i have
eyes and i mean to imply the word see
you can figure it out from the rhyme
what's an emoji is it one character
i don't yeah it counts as one character
okay but anyway if you're having trouble
use that and don't hesitate to use
uh multiple tweets linked together use
the plus symbol at the bottom of a tweet
to make to add a tweet to the thread
this could be great cool yeah love it
okay
also your son is laughing at maybe us
but i think you i believe he's
snickering
yeah it didn't sound like you were
sniffling okay
uh thanks for taking care of the yelling
cat incidentally zachary
oh no he's gone operatic on us it's true
um setting aside all ethical concerns
what surprising new forms and features
could humans be selectively bred to
possess
furthermore what forms and features are
we likely to engineer into future
generations
where do you think crispr cast nine
takes us
my own question in the uh remote
future i hope that humans suck a great
deal last night
um no so you know i will give my
usual um disclaimer about crispr cast
nine
we have the typewriter but we don't have
the genetic
uh the the rosetta stone um nobody
speaks gene
is the problem nobody speaks teen we
cannot write jeans de novo
right so um i'm skeptical
for two reasons one our technology isn't
as good as the
brochure would have you believe at
making improvements and b
nature is really hard to beat now there
are problems this is i'm sorry but i
mean this is exactly why gain of
function research is what it is it's
like we can't do this yet so we're going
to
let evolution take a shot and see if it
can create kind of the neighborhood of
what we're looking for yeah you use
serial packaging i mean in fact
that crazy paper the christian anderson
paper in nature that keeps being pointed
to
from like march or april of last year
yeah it says well this isn't a
designed virus because we would have
thought the spike protein
would fail with this confirmation you
could take it for me if i had been doing
this research i would not have created
that thing
right which you know it is true i think
that nobody would have designed the
spike protein we got it is not true that
the
protocols we use in the lab wouldn't
have put together that spike protein
um i want do you think that's
intentionally confusing
do you think you think he's he was
putting that out into the world in order
to be confusing because he's certainly
aware of what serial passaging and
gain of function research is well i
would just say that the history
of those two papers the lancet paper and
which is like the 27 multi-author paper
just saying
yeah don't worry about it nothing to see
here let's put it at this you've got
dasic on one on the lancet paper and
you've got dasic
not named in the second one but there is
an email chain that puts him behind it
and so
uh i do have the sense he was a police
consultant yeah the paper
um you know i hesitate to say anybody
deliberately wrote anything that they
knew was false on the other hand it's
really hard to figure out how somebody
who is as prominent would have come up
with something so
obviously and transparently wrong well
but i mean
but but it has worked
yes right like the the confusion like it
didn't it hadn't even occurred to me i
think we've said this on this live
stream before
it hadn't even occurred to me until
maybe after we were on mar even at the
end of january
that some people heard lab lake and
thought
created de novo from scratch by humans
right
like it literally never occurred to me
that someone could hear loudly can think
that and that's partially you know my
ignorance
but it also like that anderson
paper specifically like
created that narrative it created it and
i don't know if it existed before well
so at least the following at least the
fact that
people not knowing what this these sorts
of techniques
are would hear oh did this leak from a
laboratory and might think you know
diabolical geniuses writing viruses in
private for you know weapons purposes or
whatever
it was incumbent on those who are well
placed in this to say actually
that's not what's being discussed this
what we are discussing is something like
the hybridizing of viruses that we get
from nature
or the use of serial passaging to
enhance viruses that we get from nature
or a combination thereof
or the splicing of a gene individually
from some place that we want
however we don't believe that that
happened because and then make your damn
argument
but that they didn't do that they took
the advantage of people's
um fanciful imaginations as to what was
being alleged in order to hide and say
none of that
could possibly have happened and you'd
have to be a fool to think it could
right
right and so yes
it is uh it is extremely misleading
yeah at best okay
um
i have two number eights here for some
reason uh my absolute
oh so my absolute favorite dot this
probably came in before
before we were talking about it my
absolute favorite dr seuss book is i had
trouble in getting to sell a salute
it's difficult to find but so worth it a
good lesson on facing one's fears and
humorous on multiple levels would
recommend to all your viewers
so yes as as as i did
um project veritas recorded cnn morning
meetings during the election
i heard a group of people believing
everything they published at that moment
i realized how much trouble we're in how
are we going to fix this country if
we're not on the same moral spectrum
yeah i i heard those same
reports and i will say that i think this
is a key
insight that these discussions on the
inside don't sound like
the villainous people that you imagine
they sound like
people who are in a room full of people
who won't challenge
wrong ideas and so they get carried away
and basically there's a sense of like
well we know what the truth is and it is
our job to dispense it
rather than it is our job to report and
let people decide yeah
um and so anyway it very easily goes off
the rails but yeah um
it is it is interesting how many things
are broken and how
deeply and it is uh we're gonna have to
fix this but it's not entirely obvious
how that gets done
yeah you're at 37 minutes okay
um well we are going to keep going for a
while
uh how am i oh i remember who waddington
is now so
we got three questions here i'm like i
just don't know who these people are i
don't know how to respond to them
but this first one i actually how might
waddington's canalization of the
epigenetic landscape
pertaining to 21st century digital
behaviors is social media and epigenetic
canyon
so i think just this this term
canalization is very useful and i think
it's
it's it's a brilliant term because it's
one of the few terms of art that
actually
immediately evokes what it's supposed to
um so the idea that there are
um i i usually think of it as
developmental but that you end up you
know we we have much more capacity than
we use
and then by using one particular path a
canal say um
you know imagine water finding its way
down hills you have you know five paths
that it's taking
and then as the water starts to be
funneled for whatever initial condition
that maybe doesn't matter at all and
maybe does have an adaptive
value um it starts to funnel into one
more than the other
ultimately you end up with only one and
as those other streams dry up you
actually
the the ability of water to flow into
any of those other former channels
becomes
um almost nil or perhaps completely now
and so then at the cellular level you
would get something
like um apoptosis like actually cell
death and you don't you don't have
your neuron die off as we have you know
we're born
or at least very early in development as
embryos we have many more neurons than
we do by the time we're three or so
and that's not you know that's not a
problem that's a feature
yep so the analogy that the the question
questioner is asking is about social
media and
there's no question that there is a lot
of this going on
and one has to keep in mind that the
algorithms that then
create the channels that people find are
not stable which has two
impacts it means that a
it is very hard to track impact right
for
you know just ask yourself this question
has anybody kept
track of the changes in the algorithms
in a way that a future historian could
go back and say well
did we go crazy because of x behavior of
the platforms so that they could check
and say well actually no that's not true
because
here the behavior happened and the the
response to it didn't happen until six
months later or something like that
as far as i know nobody's doing the
history and so we can't even check
what's true we don't we can't even
evaluate what
world we're living in right um so it's a
it's a pernicious uh world rather than
a natural world yeah and
the other thing what is the other thing
the other thing
i said there were two impacts of this in
social media canalization and social
media yeah
so one is that the instability
causes um
a discontinuity between the path that
was and the path it is and the other
thing is that you can't check
what is taking place and correct your
own behavior relative to it you know
right for example so that's i guess
that's a canalization so you know the
usual metaphor there are silos
um but canalization once you're on a
different path you can't see into the
next
is that that's what you're saying so
you're saying something different no
matter what you're doing let's say that
you
come up with a mechanism for
reaching out to people who aren't in
your silo in a way that causes them
to interact with your stuff
and do so positively and then the
algorithm
changes and so instead of being in
contact with the people that you had
found you're in contact with something
adjacent that doesn't respond to you so
well
and you don't know whether your behavior
has changed or whether or not or you've
been moved by something you don't know
you and i don't know why the
rate of accumulation of subscribers to
our youtube
channel and i would say that in
reference to my twitter
account the same thing is true suddenly
these numbers slowed to a crawl
slowed to an absolute freaking crawl and
it is hard to imagine that this is in
any way natural because at the same time
viewership is up going up so
something has occurred yeah and the the
adjacent
channel the eclipse channel is
continuing to go up as
anyway yeah so there's some there's
something going on there yeah something
going on but in any case the inability
to
even know you know even if you could
just say look it's static
and i'm going to now learn how to move
around this landscape
right that would be a very different
world to do that right
you don't get to do that now um
i don't know who the first person in the
suggestion in is rather please consider
interviewing bill whittle and scott
adams on the topics of trump pathos and
pro-america unity i feel that such crush
crush i feel that such cross-aisle
discourse would be fruitful in service
and example to others
hashtag heal the divide yep i think
those are
they're very interesting i barely i know
scott adams better of course
um but yeah i think you know reasonable
people on the so-called other side not
not that we really have an other side
given the
uh eclectic um you know what a side i'm
on
tell me i'm on the side of humanity what
i know oh man
but that's so sick of it that includes
future humanity i am too like i was i
was
i was much more of a
missing throat but then you ever were
when we were first together and
really until i started teaching yeah um
but uh
but that includes future humanity which
uh is
you know i'm often i often have an
easier time around the
non-human members of our you know
inhabitants of our planet but yeah i
think so we need we need them around
future humanity is
is not pissing me off nearly so much yet
yeah
whereas the work are busy being
furiously pissed off by past humanity
yes they have a gun to the head of
future humanity which if future humanity
knew about it would be none too pleased
okay and then um this one just because
we say that we
answer questions in this first hour
roughly by the dollar amount and so this
one came in at a high dollar amount but
i don't know what it means
uh is there an attempted cancellation of
heart capital h-a-r-t
at the moment take your time i have no
idea what that means i don't know what a
heart
is who heart is i i don't know okay
i don't know um i'm not you know at some
point when we get our new
um when the new question asking system
goes online
there's going to be some slightly more
complicated rubric and i don't
know that i will we won't feel quite so
compelled to answer questions that we
just have no idea
what that means but there it is um
nature announced one percent of science
nature
the journal announced be cooler if it
wasn't
sure enough it's like nature announced
and scientists now think
it's follow nature
not the journal no no i mean you could
but i mean i get their table of contents
every week but yeah
i'm occasionally edified by them
nature announced one percent of
scientists capture more than one-fifth
of global citations
are one percent of scientists genius or
uh is eigenvector centrality flawed
or something else and why can't i easily
access academic articles
oh my god so that question that second
question deserves
well frankly its own complete podcast
like not just its own episode but like
someone needs to devote a podcast it's a
deep rabbit hole
yeah and we did i think it was like i
think it was episode six frankly that we
spent half of the time talking about
peer review
and the problems they're in but um
you know i'm looking i'm in the
scientific literature to some degree
every day
and um when our
current positions at princeton come to
an end this summer that will become
much much much harder and
i don't and the fact that most people
don't have academic positions at all
and so you know most people are
compelled that they wouldn't understand
the literature anyway and so they don't
really need access to it
but you know what that does is that it
allows the the
people who are masquerading as like
science journalists and some of them
actually are but many of them really are
not and do not understand anything
uh to report out to you what the what
the scientists are actually saying
and as we have revealed over and over
and over again on this podcast
many times they get it wrong and
sometimes they get it wrong because the
science is bad
and they didn't know and sometimes they
get it wrong because the science
journalists don't know what they're
doing and they're incompetent
but even if you feel like you don't have
the background to interpret it it would
be better if we all had access
to the entire scientific literature and
this was something we talked about
you know starting almost a year ago when
we started these podcasts
at that point so much of the coveted
literature was on pre-print servers that
it really was available to everyone
and it was like the wild west in the
good sense yep
um so the wild west in the grass
right yep um cats were tall and the
women were strong
and all the children were above average
exactly why can't i easily access
academic
articles yeah uh so you know to be
returned to
but i wish we all could and i know that
you know we are in this privileged
position at the moment and we're about
to lose that privileged position and
there are a few ways in
but they're clunky and kludgy and not
you still don't get the kind of access
that you do
if you are frankly faculty
student or staff at an institution of
higher ed and that's that's pretty much
the access um i would also point out
a you paid for the research you were
entitled to
see the product of it your tax dollar is
hard at work i mean nih and nsf
fund so much of this stuff that the idea
that this was privately
generated and therefore the that it's
and they're entitled to profit on it and
hide it from us is preposterous um this
motivated
um why am i blanking on his name
the internet's own boy aaron schwartz
aaron schwartz uh was driven to commit
suicide believing the same thing
he attempted to liberate literature um
and was hounded uh to an early grave
and so anyway many of us many of us get
the
severe problem here um and
frankly it's time it's time to do
something about it as for the first part
of the question are one percent of
scientists geniuses or is
are the eigenvector centrality flawed or
something else um
some scientists are geniuses for sure
are is that the one percent of
scientists who are capturing one-fifth
global citations
um a tiny percentage of those i would
think um but
you know a lot of those global citation
indices are based on
popularity and being adept with the
social part of the system rather than
being particularly adept with the
science
yeah i was going to say the same thing
which is that in a perfectly functional
system you might find
that one percent of the scientists were
capturing
uh something it was just and it was it
meant that we were actually making
progress faster than we would if those
people were cited less commonly
right and if you and if you think about
the way science works you may
need an awful lot of people hunting to
make a small number of fines that change
everything
absolutely so there's nothing inherently
wrong with that um but i agree with you
i think the chances that the most highly
cited people are the most insightful i
mean for one thing you know
given the way things work people with
some seniority
uh through peer review have access to
what everybody else is working on and
they steal a ton of stuff and so they do
um you know it would not be surprising
if the uh
the most adept thieves ended up in that
elite category of highly cited authors
also charlatans who managed to surf the
academic landscape
imagine that yeah next question
um have you ever heard the term cultural
literacy and since you didn't know who
jar jar binks was and you've probably
never seen star wars star wars do you
think you two are culture literate
um so we didn't know who jar jar binks
was we just couldn't
imagine what the thing looked like and
we have seen star wars but we're just
not big fans
yeah yeah we saw it we saw the originals
when they came out right the three
starting in whatever it was 1977 when we
were tiny yeah
um but we haven't seen any of the rest
of them and
uh i mean cultural literacy to me
more often refers to being familiar with
the idea that other cultures you know
at least in anthropology which is you
know field from which i
you know in with which i am familiar um
it refers more to really understanding
what parts of what you understand to be
true and universal are actually
particular to
your own state of being and so you know
at a moment
in the world when there is so much
you know pop everything being produced
the idea that it is anyone's
responsibility to be
to to be knowledgeable about all of the
stuff out there
um is absurd and so you know it's just
like saying oh to be literate you have
to have read
everything that was written before 2000
or something like everything
yeah nope that's not what literacy means
just like that's not what cultural
literacy should mean yeah
um i imagine that there's different this
question may have a different
meaning of cultural literacy and i think
it's probably being used a lot but
there's got to be some sort of if you're
totally tuned out
then it does cost you in terms of what
you can say about
why human beings are behaving the way
they are right if you've never been on
social media how would you know
what these people were responding to for
example um
but there i mean so i'm again for
another time i would be
it would be interesting for us to
to pretend to be on totally opposite
sides of that issue
because i think i am natively a bit more
towards the i'm actually not going to
know that thing i'm not going to expose
myself to that i'm more of a light
and you know i was never on social media
until 2017
and even as a teenager i i didn't i
didn't go there i didn't follow
you know there was no social media in
the mid late 80s but
um i i explicitly avoided the trends and
the fashions and listening to what other
people were listening to
and you know reading the things that
everyone was reading at the moment
because it it
seemed to me then um
like it was at risk of being
so much information that was social
and it was obscuring whatever value
there might be in any of those
things because it was of the moment and
social rather than having
had time to cement itself into meaning
that it would be even hard for a person
who was trying to find the meaning in
any given thing
um you know what that meaning might be
of course
drowning in information and starving for
meaning i forget who
who said that but um i'm not arguing
that you wouldn't necessarily
you might be better off and smarter if
you've never been on
social media on the other hand you would
be limited in terms of your ability to
say
why people are behaving the way they are
yep if you just had no
experience with it if you didn't know
what it was like to have a post get a
bunch of likes and have some other thing
that you were more fond of getting on
and
you know no and having having a shared
cultural base is absolutely meaningful
and so you know you and i
um you know it's been like we're we've
we now use the word grok on a regular
basis and
i used it very occasionally before i
re-read strangers in a strange land by
heinlein
i don't know three four years ago
actually no it was it was i actually i
was actually reading it on our study
abroad in ecuador trip so that would
have been
five years ago um and
you know it would just at that point
being re-exposed to
it in context in that novel went like oh
now this this is actually a good word
we're going to use that
and when you say it to an audience for
instance that doesn't necessarily know
what it means
use it in context enough it becomes
meaningful whereas
if we refer to you know 42 being the
answer to life the universe and
everything
you can't really you can't derive that
from first principles that we're talking
about the hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy and yet you and i
are not going to stop referring to the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy because
that one's important to us
and was formative just like zeus right
like you know those
those three things you know feel
relevant to us and so we are helping to
create a sort of cultural
milieu here and there will be other
stuff of value that we're not familiar
with
and then there's also a lot of stuff
that we're just not paying attention to
and some of that will have value but a
lot of it won't
and you have to you you do end up
instantiating some rules and they will
never be perfect yep
and there's just too much to know at all
as you
alluded to earlier yeah um
okay two more and then we'll skip to
we'll go to
three more and then we'll go to the next
ones
as a self-published author i almost
exclusively rely on amazon kdp
which i don't know what that is but i
think it's clear in um
uh with the rest of the question so as a
self-published author i almost
exclusively rely on amazon kdp it's an
amazing tool
i was already having trouble just giving
away free pdfs of my original work while
watching crappy woke remakes get
mainlined
now i fear amazon might pull my stuff
not even for anything in the work itself
but for simply being pro-trump and
center-right
what can authors do when conventions are
closed do to covet and block people
and and people block ads online
um so that is
a real question to which we don't have
the answer and it's part of the reason
that
um well it's one tiny part of the reason
that can that lockdowns
have to end soon there there are two
levels of this there is no answer to
meat
there's no answer um for individuals
to overcome the thing right there can't
be
it doesn't mean that there is not a
collective response answer and there's a
lot of stuff
in blockchain space for example that
suggests a possible answer to this
question and it's probably something
that we need to do
a podcast on so that you can get a sense
for what people are thinking about
if things get worse right yeah book
burning continues
um what do we do and uh anyway
we should probably put that together
okay um
if cats so this is a two-part question
i'm just going to read one so we can get
to some more
if cats domesticated themselves we
attracted mice that attracted them
could a similar thing be happening with
deer
yeah of course i like this question yeah
yeah and then in fact
and we do we actually there is there is
published research out and i had some
students
who did their own small versions of it
as you know quarter-long research
projects
um that show that in industrialized area
in like in urban areas
uh deer are changing
when in the like when in the circadian
cycle
they're active so they are responding to
us and that doesn't that doesn't say
domesticating that says evolving but
uh i suspect that yeah they are
domesticating themselves i
think i think it's an artificial
distinction i think there's a question
of
what the niche is in and around people
getting as a subset
um i don't know i think it's a subset i
think that
you can be evolving without being being
domesticated of course but
i don't there is a niche
it is near people some of those niches
are
deer like they're not going to move into
our homes
be too dangerous um some of those niches
are
cat-like the interesting thing in the so
but adapting to deal with humanity's
you know spewing of light everywhere for
instance as say
i don't know if chickadees are king
let's do it but you know just pick some
songbird that they're that that no one
is saying like
they seem to be there are lots of
organisms that are doing better
as a result of our activity but with
which we have no particular
relationship and are not you know you
know other than those of us who like the
birds to be around
we're not benefiting from them being
around no one is talking about them
being domesticated
but they are evolving in response to
being
in our milieu right all i'm saying is
uh and we have to be careful about this
there are lots of things you can't draw
a border between that are nonetheless
real but i'm not sure what the border
even means
in this case with deer no with what it
means to self-domesticate
versus to evolve to some niche that is
created by
humans well one of the things that has
been talked about i don't know that i
stand by this
but um one of the sets of traits that
people often point to when they're
saying things like you know are humans
you know did humans self-domesticate for
instance right um or you know how do we
you know what is it that we're seeing
like what is happening with foxes when
they get domesticated
in like the russian experiments is a
pitomorphosis
uh you know which is often called
neoteny but not he's actually a subset
of pedomorphis it's not the other way
around so it's
it's it's retaining of juvenile
characteristics
in the adult form um and we know that
you know when you're an adult you are
reproductively capable so while you are
reproductively capable you retain
juvenile characteristics like bigger
eyes
and bigger hands and feet or um i wanted
to say something about the ears but i'm
not sure
if there's anything about the ears but
again oh floppy ears in the case of
canids
yeah we've got lots of metamorphosis
that has nothing to do
with anything you would call
self-domestication i guess what i'm
saying
you've got that backwards though so it i
again i'm not saying that i'm going to
defend
the definition but if the definition is
if it's right then you would you would
be looking for evidence of metamorphosis
in order to start thinking okay that's
self-domestication absent the
metamorphosis then it's not
self-domestication
not all pitomorphosis is evidence of
self-determination i know you're not
saying that i just don't i don't
my sense is every time i run into this
self-domesticated thing and the fact
that it is applied to people did we
domesticate ourselves yeah i find it
uninteresting too
not even interesting yeah i find it a
garbage category that's been added and i
just caused
the conversation to become more confused
but that was just an example like i'm
not
this question isn't about
self-domestication it's about
domestication
and whether or not domestication
inherently involves
a paedomorphosis as it appears to have
in cats
and in dogs and uh in
wild canids and i don't know what the
other examples are
but so you know that's that's all and
again i'm not saying that i'm defending
this definition
yeah but that if we found reason to
defend it then that would be an
indicator of okay
these things are adapting and thriving
around humans but we see no evidence of
metamorphosis therefore
um we're not seeing them as domesticated
i'm not sure i think neither you and i
are particularly interested
in you know exactly where these
boundaries are yeah but um
i think just trying to figure out what
what you would need to be true
uh if you agreed on definitions okay one
more question here and then we'll go to
this hour um this one is important
actually i'm glad we got to this one a
scientist trained in both taxonomy and
critical thinking
please help settle a critically
important debate once and for all
is a hot dog a sandwich love the channel
thanks for all you do
well they're not gonna like this aren't
they but a hot dog is in fact a calzone
i mean
okay all right see yup good did it right
gordian knot
oh okay so zach you want to put on your
your mic to tell us that or
are you just gonna yeah i just i was
just saying that it could arguably
be a taco a hot dog yes
excellent excellent okay
um so zach did you put in a line for me
here
i did you did happy belated birthday oh
captain my captain
that's for you thank you yes
everyone else in the family has a
birthday in april except the animals
they were all born in march
the non-human animals yep different
marches
and different drummers totally different
drummers
yeah um okay here's a three-part
question or at least one written in
three lines here okay um brett
oh boy this has a lot of shorthand so
i'm going to try to read it hi friend
um to me brett to me
you can you can read it with me if you
want although you're likely to have a
harder time with it than i am
to me brett you incarnate mind power by
j brown
extracts quote now the educators they
call it esp
positive thinking right some of the
people across the other side of the pond
call it vibes
vibrations astrology and all those
different things you understand but i
call it
what it is and what it is mind power
somebody needs to help us
just give us a chance brothers across
the nation you've got to get yourself
together and unified
we need information pass on that right
on information
that love power funky robot i don't know
what's going on that mind power
uh jb experience what it is is what it
is you can't change it don't fool
yourself deal with it
anyway this is echo so okay this is
i don't know what to do with that uh i
mean
would it be is what it were i have the
sense but i don't
yeah i mean sure if it's good this is
gonna be james brown
j browned this is gonna be james brown
then the funky robot
uh reference i think oh okay yeah
cool yeah and i just sorry echo i
couldn't i can't
make sense of it and brett actually
would know the lyrics probably if if he
spent time with it but um cool if memes
are primordial
if memes are primordial abcs of human
culture
are psychedelic aesthetics the key
expression of them inheritable culture
ps i chose 24.99 as the dollar amount
because it's kind of funny must be my
phenotype
i feel like someone has said that before
maybe the same person
if memes or primordial abcs of human
culture
are psychedelic aesthetics the key
expression of them inheritable culture
i don't get it um psychedelics
are a couple things they are
boundary breakers between natural
borders of consciousness
and unconsciousness and
that is basically functioning like
um it is basically
an uptick in serendipity in other words
serendipity uptick in cognitive
serendipity so
your thoughts become more garbagey
including your visual thoughts
and that's a tremendous amount of fun
and it can lead you to jump gaps that
you would not
temp being overly canalized in your
normal cognitive state so
i don't know that it's an ultimate
expression but it's like a hack that
allows you
this is key expression psychedelic
aesthetics
the key expression of some inheritable
culture
yeah i like where you're going but i i
think i think that that made some more
sense what you were just doing there i
don't think
cytostatics is the key expression of
memes and heritable culture quite yeah
it works
let's just say psychedelics are a hack
to escape
the canalization of thought that is
overly
constrained for functionality that is to
say
you take the day off and you allow
yourself to jump tracks that you
wouldn't otherwise jump
in order to find thoughts that you
couldn't otherwise reach and see things
that
aren't actually there and you might
consider taking the next morning off too
you know sure depending
yeah you could take a mental health and
jubilation day
oh we got a we got a uh
i don't even know what to call that a
lovey kissy emoji with a substantial uh
dollar amount here from
from al thank you fantastic thanks so
much they want all the power to do all
this this is something different sorry
switching here they want all the power
to do
all the things and when it comes to your
life tyranny it
oh wait sorry this is this is a seuss
poem
i was not reading it like a suspect i'm
gonna go back yeah
they want all the power to do all the
things and when it comes to your life
tyranny it brings i do not like them
they will put us in camps i do not like
them they are intellectual tramps
[Laughter]
yes yes yeah awesome i like it
um i can't see all this because
google is weird there we go what do you
think of the concept that group
consciousness is a recent phenomenon i.e
computer
and the web and we are making merely
waking our way through this information
collectively with selection taking place
but in the wrong way
no collective consciousness is ancient
yeah
um in fact it's weirder now
that's true it's gotten a little weird
yeah there's a lot of noise on that
channel
but yeah it's ancient we've we've talked
about that elsewhere but um
our argument is that we don't understand
consciousness because we assume
that it is individual in origin
and then it is a paradox because what
good is it to have a subjective
experience of anything
whereas if you imagine that
consciousness's purpose is to allow two
brains to share an abstract idea so they
can parallel process it and then once
you have the ability to take something
and abstract it and pass it along
with language you also have the ability
to juggle it in your own mind and that's
useful too
so individual consciousness is secondary
okay there are only a few questions here
most of them are just comments so we're
going to try to get through
these dugan from a league of their own
um we are told that this is a quote from
the character jimmy dugan in a league of
their own
are you growing there's no growing
there's no growing in cancer culture
roger hornsby was my manager and he
called me a talking pile of pig [ __ ] and
i and did i grow no no you know why
because there's no growing in cancer
culture
the quote involves the term castle
culture i'm a little surprised about
that
a league of their own yeah that's what
90s
i don't know yeah is that going to look
up a league of their own and see when it
came out
okay but you're right there's no growing
in cancer culture
that's true right imperial college
researchers reported emu-like red blood
cells and collagen
fibers in dinosaur fossils ancient art
worldwide depicts dragons
how to set the probability that large
land dinos coexisted with humans
no yeah emu like red blood cells and
collagen fibers and dinosaur fossils i
don't know that research i'd be
i'd be curious to see what the actual
research says but um
emu and the other oh it's not rattites
anymore the um
what whatever post raptites no i don't
know
rattites has been renamed um to include
um
kiwis uh the paleo gnats
well done the old jaws uh so the
we've got birds there's paleons and
there's neonates with a silent g in the
middle of both
and the paler nets are considered to be
the
the closest to the basal representation
of of birds that are living on our
planet right now the neonates being
every other bird out there the
paleontologists include the rattites
which are the big uh flightless birds
uh emus and cassowaries and ostriches
and rias and i think apionus
elephant birds would have been in that
list but they're extinct now they're on
madagascar
and kiwis are also in there they're
little flightless birds
um so if they are in fact the closest
representative that we have alive on
earth today
to a basal bird and we
i would put a lot of money on the
evolutionary conclusion
that birds and dinosaurs are of all the
clades that anyone could name
that most people could name are each
other's closest relatives
then it's not inherently surprising that
we should find some emu like characters
uh in what is it in dinosaur fossils
right so but then you know ancient art
so that's one piece of evidence that
doesn't say anything about um big flying
dinosaurs with humans um ancient art
worldwide depicts dragons
um that doesn't surprise me either but
you know it's less it's less clear how
you sort of dismantle that
uh scientifically as evidence for us
having existed with
dragons i agree and the chances of them
having left no
evidence where we would find it is
pretty low yeah
all right to answer your question a
league of thrones came out in 1992
1992. thank you yeah it was a pretty
imprecise prediction
the 90s yes it was it was uh
suitably broad you said birds and
dinosaurs are the
other they're each other's closest
relatives just to be consistent with
what we've said birds are dinosaurs so
it is birds in the non-avian dinosaurs
that are each other's
closest relatives there we've
closed off one attack vector i look
forward
to the moment when uh the attacks are at
that level
all right yeah i'm like i'm i'm in i'll
i'll go there
i'll drink to that yeah okay how about
hashtag unlock the doc
for the twitter hashtag i like it but
we've already set this in motion
unlock the dock so maybe if um if people
if people are listening to this
and have the space in their tweets using
both could be
could be useful to see if um just to
start to collect those but hashtag
unlock the doc doc
um and hashtag loose the seuss
okay we got um
just a few more here an idea could
plants evolve toxins easily destroyed by
fire and cooking
seed dispersed by organisms capable of
technological civilization seems like
could be a good strategy
what um so i mean there's two different
questions there
plants do evolve toxins that are easily
destroyed by fire and cooking but not
because fire and cooking existed at the
point that they evolved those toxins
you know proteins they really mean fire
or heat
it says fire slash cooking i know well
okay so
i can't mind read so i'm just reading i
know but just in terms of parsing the
question
to figure out what we're we're
responding to
denaturing proteins by heat is a very
common thing right
then that pre-exists humans using fire
or cooking
is what i was saying right so maybe i
missed what the question is shooting for
just could plants so the question
seems to imagine that maybe there aren't
toxins that um are destroyed by fire and
cooking and there are basically all
proteins
get what's called denatured which means
they lose theirs at their tertiary
protein structure
and so they don't then do the thing that
they're they would normally do but they
still
um have a caloric and nutritional value
um that's true for all all proteins
become denatured at high heat although
some are you know they're all adapted to
different levels of heat um
so i believe cooking also
uh breaks down secondary structure
nutrition out of things like meat i
don't remember
i don't remember if that's the case but
that may be the case um
but yeah so see so the question
i think presumes that that there isn't
uh already structure that is in fact
uh broken down by heat and i think it in
some ways it sort of reverses causal
causality it's not like plants don't
need to search for the thing
like humans started cooking and you know
really this is so this was a hypothesis
it was already in circulation but
richard wrangham
in his you know excellent primatologist
richard wrangham in his
i don't know i forgot 2000 something
book called catching fire
really spells out the hypothesis in
depth that it may be actually cooking
that helped make us fully human that it
was
that there are no even at the point that
anthropologists started doing their
thing in like the late
19th century 19th century
um and there was some there were some
tales from like missionaries and
anthropologists about
finding cultures that didn't use fire um
those
are almost certainly species that was
probably you know some combination of
some sort of like
racist imaginings and they just didn't
look very hard
so all known cultures
have used all known modern cultures
including back into the 19th century
used fire and cooking
uh in wrangham's formulation and i'm
compelled to buy it
uh does does so many things and we're
not going to spell them out here this is
another thing that we do in our book
um including making many more calories
available
to those who eat cooked food as opposed
to eating the same food raw
it also makes the time spent chewing
much lower and that sounds like this
trivial thing but apparently some
there's some analyses that suggest that
if
um if we if humans
not including all the soft crap that we
eat now but if humans
like typical hunter-gatherers not at the
extremes not the poles where the diet is
all meat but
um with a somewhat typical ratio of like
meat to plant matter
we're eating entirely non-cooked food we
would spend i think it's something like
five or six days
hours every single day just chewing and
that actually
obviously does get in the way of doing
other things at that point yep
you can multitask but uh
well um anyway i would i would just add
that with respect to the denaturing of
proteins
the way to think about it is not that it
has to evolve that the protein can be
um uh deactivated by
human technologies the way to think
about it is the enzymes themselves
are predicated on an environment in
which they function
and basically you have a protein which
is a string of amino acids that has
lots of little charges on the surface
and those charges have they find a
conformation that is
most stable relative to a given ph in a
given temperature
and the point is if you change the ph
and temperature what you do is you
change the affinities
of these charges and they end up finding
some conformation that doesn't actually
work
so the point is the enzyme has a
tolerance for
heat that is based on what the creature
in nature is encountering
and then what we do with heat is we put
enough heat in there that the point is
it
increases the activity of the substrate
and the thing
finds some folding pattern that just
isn't functional as a natural thing so
it's not something that has to evolve
for humans it's something that exists
there that humans can exploit
yeah bingo um
someone asks not for the first time will
you address the revolutionary phenotype
uh we are aware of it but neither of us
have read it yet and
um it's i guess you could say we're
avoiding it but we're not intentionally
avoiding it we just haven't haven't done
it yet so
we have nothing to say about it at this
point because we have not read it
uh never forget aaron schwartz yes um
best of luck in all you do thank you
and is zack zack or zack spelled zack
zack or zack
and is it short for some homophone of
zachary i'd like to get this right
in my behind the curtain appreciation
tips
so it's z-a-c-k in its short form and is
in fact short for
zachary with a z-a-c-h-a-r-y yep there
you go
um three more questions and then we're
out for
who has more steam in the biology
research community dr seuss or dr dre
why did you and your brother decide to
give quentin tarantino his big break
yes what i don't know i have no idea all
right i don't know what that means
and i just said i'd read all the rest of
them um so that we will pick up some
next week that we missed from the first
hour i'm just reading all the ones that
came in this era because there weren't
that many
uh slavery predates history natural and
sexual selection directs the evolution
of species
but how much of an effect did market
selection have
and then i'm just going to stop there
because i don't know what this
last one is a third part to the question
i don't know what it's referring to
um how much effect did market selection
have
i don't know what that means i'm trying
to read it
so slavery does predate history uh for
evolution of sure but how much effect
i don't know what the question means
okay figure it out okay so i'm gonna
find one
i'm gonna i don't want to end there i'm
to find one more question if i can
figure it out from the first hour
that
okay here's two questions
one comment one question
i just became the uncle of a second
little girl thank you for helping me
come up with gifts to bring along this
week
awesome excellent and uh what is your
recommendation
on the johnson johnson vaccine for
people in their 20s 30s and early 60s
you two are my only hope
well we've covered this a little bit it
depends on
your situation um i would say it's
lowest priority for somebody in their
20s the later in your 20s
you are the
more you might consider it i think with
all of these things
the danger is that we don't know what we
don't know and that there's a long-term
hazard with all of the vaccines
that is significant and not being
properly discussed
so delaying is valuable but you're not
going to be able you know if it would
take 25 years to know for sure whether
these vaccines are going to have a
important impact that we don't foresee
like causing an autoimmunity or tumors
or who knows
you can't wait 25 years that's not the
scale of which this matters
and so you're going to have to make a
call and the problem is you're not going
to make a safe call
you're going to make a call based on two
things
that are lousy one is the risk of
getting
coveted and the harms that come from it
and the other is the risk that there's
something about these vaccines
that we don't know and we're going to
find out too late and
you know those are things you have to
juggle but there's no there's no simple
answer here
there is no simple answer i do think the
question was specifically about johnson
johnson compared to the other vaccines
so um let me let me speak a little bit
to that sure
um we got asked last week about whether
um
in light of the uh relatively few
serious adverse effects from the modern
and fizer vaccines if our priors had
changed about
our sense of of their risk and i i said
no and brett said a little
and i think i'm actually i i want to
correct the record and say yeah a little
um the longer it is since they started
being rolled out massively
um without very many um serious adverse
effects
the better i feel about them and that's
not to say that there aren't possible
long-term side effects that could not
possibly have begun to manifest yet but
i feel a little bit better about them
and the johnson johnson vaccine
obviously does not have that going for
it because it's
it's brand new that said um
i would prefer for me i would prefer the
johnson johnson vaccine to the modern or
pfizer vaccine and i very much hope that
americans and you know people all over
the world but i very much i know that
americans at this point are not given a
choice that if you show up at a vaccine
spot you're given whatever it is they
have and so far that's been between
modern and pfizer
and soon that will be between modern
advisor and johnson and johnson but you
don't
have any way of knowing in advance what
you'll be getting nor do you have a
choice at the moment
why would i prefer johnson johnson at
this point even though it doesn't even
have the several month track record that
moderna and pfizer have
because as we have said many times
previously
while it is not a traditional vaccine it
has
um one very new thing associated with it
whereas the rna the mrna vaccines
moderna and pfizer have two very new
things
and so the two very new things with
modern alphyser
are the mrna which is like the active
ingredient
delivered via lipid nanoparticles both
of those are brand new in humans as of
the end of last year uh and then the
johnson johnson vaccine
like astrazeneca slash astrazeneca
oxford
is a dna vaccine as such it is actually
classified as gene therapy rather than a
vaccine
but it's doing something similar to what
the mrna vaccines are doing just kind of
one step earlier
but it is wrapped in its delivery
mechanism
is an adenovirus which is a much more
tried and true delivery mechanism than
the lipid nanoparticles that the mrna
vaccines are using
and so in choosing between two vaccines
that are using brand new technology but
one of them also uses
an additional kind of brand new
technology i prefer the one that uses
one kind of brand new technology to the
those that
use two kinds of brand new technologies
and if you are
in your early 60s um i would i would
probably get it and if you're in your
20s and 30s as brett said
um i would you know i don't think those
are yet available to anyone
um without other underlying conditions
um so
um that's a that's a sort of a luxurious
position as
as is the one that we're in at this
point not having to make the decision
right so i would add that the
you're right about the totally new um
limited nanoparticle delivery
process being more risky than the
adenovirus
but i would say part of the or a big
part to me the lion's share of the
reason that the adenovirus
delivery mechanism is safer is that we
have a history an evolutionary history
with adenoviruses
right so yes you're right right more so
than the fact that this
has a track record it has some track
record but it's still new
no that's the better what's the better
reason it's the yeah the better reason
is just that
the likelihood that adenoviruses are
going to be dangerous to you
um is low because we get them and
they're they're
minor um and so using them as a delivery
mechanism is new but
your evolutionary preparedness is not
yeah
that's great good correction thank you
um
it's possible that uh almost you know
more than three and a half hours in that
we are done for the day whoa what do you
think
are we done for the day do some
logistical announcements and
and sign off yeah let's uh let's do that
okay so we will be back in a week
12 30 pacific usual time usual place
right here in our very own sauna
with our very own carnivores behind us
um
we are grateful to you and we appreciate
all the support
uh via um super chat questions and by
joining our patreons
uh and if you are not in a position to
or do not feel like contributing that
way but you appreciate us
please consider um giving good reviews
on places where you're listening to the
podcast
although i should have said that when
this was actually something that was
going on at the audio podcast
but if you also listen to the audio
podcast consider positive reviews there
um i think comments on youtube help as
well although i'm not
unless sure about that um why are you
looking at this
i'm just i don't know
[Music]
oh my god
um okay i'm gonna say to you
yes love the people who you live with i
know you do and i love you back
and eat good food and get outside and no
more crazy eyes no
i was trying to write poetry in my head
i had i was not
particularly thinking about what facial
expression
that much was clear yes we've come to
the end of this dark horse podcast
um we're going to go drink we'll be
drinking it last
i don't know do it again do it again
that was good one more and then we're
going to come to the end of this dark
horse podcast
we're going to go drinking we'll be
drinking it last or something along
those lines i don't know it was better
in the earlier iteration you can all
scroll back through the you were
supposed to stop at the end of your
little couplet and let us go oh i was
yeah
try again third time it's gonna get
worse and
that is not the result of drinking which
they know we've had cameras on us
well sometimes that goes to one or the
other of us who knows what we've got
going on at the table
all right we have we are wearing pants
um we have come to the end of this dark
horse podcast
it is time to go drinking we'll be
drinking it last
sort of sorta
you